imagine if the Earth and Moon were only
one and a half inches away from each
other in reality it's over a quarter of
a million miles but that's the scale we
used in order to visualize the ten
billion miles that Voyager 2 is traveled
this month marks 40 years that the
spacecraft has been traveling on its
mission to reach the giant planets of
our solar system and maybe just maybe
deliver this golden record containing
sounds and images of human life to any
extraterrestrials in mind encounter
since 1977 it's been traveling through
space at the rate of nearly 35,000 miles
per hour NASA even has a live tracker on
their website that tells you just
exactly how far it's gone but 10 billion
631 million eight hundred eleven
thousand eight hundred and fifty five
miles is hard to wrap your head around
so we converted the actual distance to a
human scale and headed to Governors
Island to visualize just how far away
that really is
we started by setting up our cameras one
and a half inches away from one another
to represent the distance between the
earth and the moon the real distance is
two hundred and thirty nine thousand
miles at this scale the Sun would be
about five and a half inches wide around
the size of a grapefruit and Voyager 2
would be way too tiny to see around the
size of one nanometer once we had our
cameras set up I started walking
backwards pretending to be Voyager 2 and
T on stayed behind as planet Earth
within a year the spacecraft was as far
away as Mars a planet that averages a
distance of 50 million miles from Earth
by 1979 Voyager to reach stupider
next it passed by Saturn in 1981 and
took this photo of the planet five years
later it was the first spacecraft of his
a Uranus and then it moved on to Neptune
which I passed in 1989 the last planet
on its journey since then Voyager 2 has
been traveling a course to reach
interstellar space and they didn't pass
Pluto along the way and Pluto might not
even be a planet anymore but here's the
distance on this scale just in case
you're wondering at this point Voyager 2
wasn't even halfway to its current
location so I had to do some traveling
[Music]
clearly I wasn't able to follow the path
of the Voyager 2 in fact I had to take a
ferry to get back to Manhattan but after
a boat ride and over a mile of walking I
reached a point that represents just how
far away Voyager 2 really is but it's
continuing every second currently
Voyager 2 is traveling towards Ross 248
a star that it will be nine point seven
trillion miles close to in about 40,000
years next will pass within 30 trillion
miles of Sirius the brightest star in
the sky that is over eight light-years
away from Earth using my human scale I
would have to travel a distance equal to
the whole length of Africa to get to
Sirius in real life Voyager 2 will reach
the star and about two hundred and
ninety six thousand years Voyager 2 is
only the second farthest human-made
object from Earth Voyager 1 is even
farther and has already reached
interstellar space like Voyager 2 it's
also carrying the golden record and if
you want to see the photos NASA chose to
show aliens make sure to check out this
video here
[Music]